Nik built-ins new book on hatching  Twitter is a wonderful wonderful read I  read it on the plane on the way out here  but there's there's so many great lines  in it but there's a particularly great  line where he talks about Twitter where  he talks about Twitter he quotes Mark  Zuckerberg the founder of Facebook and  describes it as a clown car that fell  into a gold mine apparently is a wine  that Zuckerberg gave to some friends  privately when was that was it sin  though he quotes him in the book he  doesn't say when when when he said it  yeah sometime in the last three years it  was recent probably early recently no no  it was more recent than that because he  was talking about in the context of a  couple of acquisitions that didn't pan  out and and he described it as these  guys were just it's just astonishing  like why won't they it was in the  context of why won't they take an  acquisition offer I mean look at these  characters the clown cars are Tony  wonder